[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dansions parler
sport l'émission à ne pas manquer si
vous êtes un amoureux du sport local on
est en plein dans les vacances scolaires
mais rassurez vous on ne prend jamais de
vacances ici quatre chroniqueurs vont
m'accompagner aujourd'hui dans cette
émission ils ont tous annulé leurs
vacances à la dernière minute
présentation en musique en corse à ma
droite c'est le vrai français et devait
partir dans la creuse pour une semaine
mémorable avec ses copains avec plein
d'activités mais il est finalement avec
nous sur ce plateau tel un grand
professionnel il ya déjà riez du club de
vélizy 78 montfort michael vista de
villes wifi star de vélizy oui oui
accessoirement cycliste accessoirement
si piste voilà bon vous n'êtes pas trop
triste d'être ici mais non pas du tout
c'est un grand plaisir toujours appuyé
en plus un environnement professionnel
en convient avec le soleil donc tout va
bien on passe de l'autre côté musical
devait partir à venise l'une des villes
les plus glamour au monde pour s'essayer
à la pole dance sera finalement avec
nous en plateau notre ambassadrice de
charme et l'aide de la grange qui nous
vient tout droit de versailles j'ai
scandale et voulait très bien très bien
et je pars vraiment à venise dans deux
semaines on va retenir normaliserait
vraiment le tout ce que je dis vive
récession
bien sûr vous voilà c'était juste une
question de date j'ai même pas eu besoin
d'annuler je suis là montpellier
dujarrier en vue qu il y avoir de
vacances dans la creuse
je suis pas sûr tout le monde soit
d'accord chez jan
pour perte à venise on passe de l'autre
côté musique il devait partir en
nouvelle-zélande pour apprendre les
techniques de passes des rugbymen all
blacks pendant plusieurs mois
finalement il regardera des vidéos sur
internet notre russell crowe à nous
pierre chevallier notre gladiateurs du
rugby-club de versailles c'est du
michael salut a tous des vidéos de sport
de sport deux jours ou des tutos mais
pas pas autre chose quand allez-vous ça
va très bien ravi d'avoir séché mes rtt
pour être présent fidèle au poste avec
tous les camarades alors on est contents
nous vous avoir avec nous en tout cas on
termine de l'autre côté musique il
devait partir en vacances sur une île
déserte à l'autre bout du monde dans une
région secrètes sur l'objectif se
ressourcer il a tellement donné sur les
dernières émissions ici mais
rassurez-vous il donnera encore plus
aujourd'hui ladies and gentleman genlis
ancien entraîneur du plaisir rugby club
est avec nous bonsoir michael quand
allez-vous toujours pareil toujours
plano forme impeccable
merci beaucoup d'avoir annulé vos
vacances oui je vous ai laissé le choix
dans la date donc vous avez profité
probablement avant de passer au
programme de l'émission hameau de
cyclisme après 2015 le vélodrome
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
accueillera-t-il à nouveau un
championnat du monde sur piste c'est en
tout cas le souhait du président de la
fédération française michel callot un
dossier de financement est à l'étude et
va être remontée d'ici le mois de
septembre organisé l'un des plus gros
rendez vous sur piste deux ans avant de
recevoir les jeux olympiques la décision
devrait bientôt être connu l'union
cycliste internationale devrait
attribuer les championnats du monde 2022
en septembre prochain pour ou contre
cette candidature vous votez pour bourg
pour yann dujarrier vous qui connaissez
le mieux le devis le mieux je savais
j'en ai parlé de la volée dit en tout
cas c'est d'ici septembre le gagner mais
de toute façon je pense que les moyens
ils seront trouvées puisque le vélodrome
accueillera dès les jeux olympiques en
2024 donc deux ans avant c'est très bien
d'avoir un
événement d'ampleur aussi aussi
importante et donc donc du coup je suis
très confiant pour cette candidature
c'est très bien qu'un jour où on pourra
pas accéder au vélodrome mais comme
j'aurais arrêté le vélo d'ici là ça ne
pose pas de souci vous pouvez peut-être
participer au championnat du monde
non hélène non mais moi je rejoins de
toute façon ce que tu dis après une
candidature c'est toujours bon à prendre
donc non pas nouvelle genre les deux
championnats du monde en moins de dix
ans au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
c'est une bonne chose assez triviale et
les structures la structure est fait est
fait pour ça donc autant là l'afer a
travaillé en main une vision des
championnats des jeux olympiques commun
dit yann grand grand cocorico
pierre chevalier on en parle souvent ici
du vélodrome nationale on parle beaucoup
de diversification d'événements qui qui
cherchent à conquérir de nouveaux
publics
quand il s'agit de d'attirer sur une
épreuve internationale sur l'activité
rénale et l'activité première de la
petite reine justement sur piste c'est
une c'est une très bonne chose et ça ça
fera office de répétition générale pour
pour 2024
sarah mènera sûrement du monde sur
l'essence même de ce sport dans un lieu
qu'elle était fait pour donc c'est une
très bonne chose nouvelle dont on a
besoin de ce type d'événement il ya une
gériez le vélodrome a besoin d'eux
non mais la france le vélodrome je ne
dirais pas que le vrai monde en a besoin
je dirais plutôt que la france en a
besoin c'est c'est vrai que le
territoire on a très peu de vélodrome
couvert sur le territoire c'est pas une
discipline qui est qui qui peut avoir la
même résonance que celle que ce que que
peu la voix qu'elle qu'elle peut avoir
dans les pays anglo-saxons et c'est bien
dommage parce que parce que beaucoup de
grands champions du tour de france
vienne vienne de la piste et donc moi je
pense que qu'il ya beaucoup beaucoup de
choses à aller chercher sur sur la sur
la piste et sur les vélodromes donc il
faut qu' il faut que cette discipline
soit soit plus présente dans ce dans
notre pays parce que parce que le
problème c'est que le tour de france se
prend toute la plage méga denis
d'éthique du cyclisme du sexisme sur le
territoire et c'est vraiment
problématique pour beaucoup d'autres
organisations et beaucoup d'autres
disciplines
nous allons maintenant passer au
programme de l'émission désolait un père
chevalier vous vouliez je sais quelque
chose qui en time exactement
nous allons maintenant passer au
programme de l'émission aujourd'hui nous
allons parler de rugby j'ai des écossais
sont venus jouer un match amical à
plaisir dans le cadre du tournoi des six
nations
nous ferons également un coup de
projecteur sur les nouveaux sports qui
devrait intégrer les jo en 2024 nous
parlerons notamment de break dance et d'
escalade
mais avant de développer ces thèmes on
va parler boxe dans ce talk
[Musique]
en boxe marvin petit a échoué dans sa
quête d'un titre européen le boxeur de
27 ans licencié dans la team farruggia
ils encourent sept incliné aux points
face aux belges francesco patera qui
boxer à domicile
la décision des arbitres a été décriée
par le clan de marvin petit on écoute sa
réaction et celle de son entraîneur jean
guy farrugia sur notre plateau la
différencie n'est qu' on était chez lui
à domicile
et voilà quoi oui il avait il avait un
entraîneur il y avait aussi le siège de
liège à liège c'est le pays qui est là
bas donc et une favori ici donc on est
chez lui quoi paris vous êtes d'accord
ça à jouer forcément le fait que que
patera ce soit à domicile tout à fait
moi j'ai regardé le combat je sais pas
combien de fois
voilà j'ai quant à la fin du combat avec
marvin j'y monte à 1 petit point
d'avancé
t'es chez lui faut pas espérer la
victoire je regarde le combat après soit
5,6 points pour marvin alors je rappelle
que marvin petit n'était pas à 100% de
ses capacités suite notamment des
problèmes familiaux ou les rejeter
quelque chose vient du verrier il ya
votre petit panneau ouais moi je
simplement encore un vol la boxe n'en
sortira pas grandie mais c'est pas la
première fois qu'il ya des scandales
j'ai beaucoup de mal avec ces
disciplines qui sont vraiment simplement
faim qui peuvent être jeu où le résultat
est donné par des juges voilà ça veut
dire que le résultat peut-être peut-être
truqués malheureusement pour ma vie n'a
pas réussi à accoucher le accouché le
belge et c'était la seule issue pour que
marvin puisse puisse gagner ce combat
déjà de toute façon quand on part sur un
combat de boxe et quand on joue à
l'extérieur on sait que on part avec un
pourcentage de victoires aux cadres en
cas de gain enfin en cas d'arrivée au
point où on part avec un ballotage
défavorable donc là la voilà c'est
encore encore une fois quelque chose qui
est qui et qui est dommageable pour pour
ce sport qui se dit le sport noble de la
boc le sport noble je trouve ça je
trouve ça dommage
la question sur ce thème marvin petit
peut-il s'en vouloir
oui ou non oui jean pierre chevallier
donc vous voyez nous a renié partagé
pour jour nice élèves non ouais enfin
petit duel entre vous et hélène et
pierre chevalier oui pourquoi ne doit
pas s'en vouloir
je pense que la décision vient pas
forcément il n'a rien à voir dans la
décision par contre il aurait pu avoir
un combat
peut-être différent ou ou avoir d'autres
actions qui permettent jusqu'à qui
aurait pu permettre de ne pas avoir une
issue comme ça mais bon après voilà ça
se termine de cette façon il aurait dû
aller chercher au cas où il aurait pu
oui il aurait pu au moins
- y aller après voilà ce qui est fait
est fait mais c'est dommage
regardez les archives je pense qu'il ya
quinze jours on en avait on en avait
parlé déjà du contexte de ce combat à
l'extérieur avec a priori sûrement ou
sans doute un arbitrage maison c'était
c'était un match piège qui nous semblait
déjà bien bien préparé la seule chose
que je puisse dire là actuellement pour
pouvoir dire qui peut s'en vouloir
c'est sur la éventuellement la stratégie
de combat d'aller chercher le ko un
petit peu plus vite un petit peu plus
fort et et de l'obtenir comme disait
comme disait yann de le coucher plus
vite parce que il était évident que dans
le contexte qu'on avait des cris qui a
priori avait été mise en place là-bas
c'est que c'est que de toute façon au
point où s'il y avait une décision est
une décision de juge à prendre
il était était perdant automatique donc
là où il peut s'en vouloir cesser
éventuellement ne pas avoir accéléré le
match et la stratégie pour aller le
choper en cao beaucoup plus vite jean
vous qui étiez on va dire entre deux
eaux est-ce que vous avez tranché
vous n'êtes plus hélène vous êtes plus
fier non mais moi j'étais mitigé parce
que le les dés sont pipés d'entrée et ça
c'est comme 18 ans et ça ne vérifie pas
le la discipline c'est dommage parce
qu'on peut pas j'étais mitigé parce que
sportivement c'est quand même un chef de
l'ing d'europe et on ne peut pas dire un
boxeur b c ou tu le mets ko août a perdu
mais non c'est pas possible parce que si
si si tous les combats de boxe se
termine et ne peut pas terminer ses
parts par ko bombay et le sport sans
rire le matin la plupart des combats il
se termine la plupart du temps au point
voilà voilà
dans le cas où les fans par ko sont
quand même beaucoup moins importante que
les les faits voilà heureusement aussi
pour la saleté mais met donc c'est pour
ça que j'étais mitigé parce que il peut
pas s'en vouloir je pense qu'il a il a
tout donné malgré le petit problème
perso qu'il avait au moment du combat
mais il n'était pas à 100% il était à 50
% de ses moyens et mais bon c'est
toujours comme ça malheureusement il
faut être à 100% au jour j c'est ça le
sport dire dire ouais mais je n'étais
pas ça pour ça c'est pour ça que je suis
passé à côté
bon là c'est un peu dommage ce trajet
vers ça derrière sa part donc non là je
suis pas d'accord mais sportivement il a
tout donné
il a tout donné et on peut pas dire un
boxer encore une fois mais c'est où tu
le mets cas où tu as perdu
non parce que c'est hasard il ya il ya
quand même des points qu'à y ait un juge
qui donne 117% 12
c'est énorme l'écart ces normes l'écart
à des gens qui vendent des juges quatre
cents us à l'ancêtre le belz challenge
là c'est bon et cesser de la tuberie
mans pour rester poli yann je dis qu'il
est pas moi je dis qu'il n'a pas sans
vouloir il a fait le job
les observateurs disent bien ce qui
crient qu'ils auraient dû dit gagner ce
qu'on se combattent pour moi il a fait
le il a fait le travail
oui bien sûr qu'il savait que que en cas
de en cas de décision arbitrale ce
serait c'était mort mais en effet c'est
difficile d'aller chercher le ko c'est
difficile de pouvoir obtenir cette le le
judo de nippon ichi comme le ippon au
judo voilà c'est pas là c'est pas la
même chose c'est pas la même chose à la
boxe donc
donc pour moi il n'a pas à s'en vouloir
simplement essayer d'aller chercher une
revanche
et parce que parce que là il s'en est il
voit qu'il a les moyens d'aller chercher
ce titre
justement il l'a proposé aux belges
francesco patera une revanche dans deux
mois est ce qui doit faire ce combat
l'origine je connais tu dois te connais
pas son programme en dire trop dessus
sont programmés mais rob est le fer
pendant qu'il est chaud oui
après ce que est ce que les promoteurs
et est ce que est ce que le camp le camp
d'en face acceptera il était très énervé
à marie voler comme ça on peut on peut
que piquer l'orgueil et donc
effectivement je pense que le camp d'en
face se posera deux fois la question
avant d'accepter le combat effectivement
avec un avec un opposant remonté comme
une pendule
ça rit ça risque d'être difficile pour
jean non je passe temps parce que c'est
bien connu le belge c'est une fois je
pense que vous restez siens je pense
quand même que finalement il aurait
peut-être dû partir en vacances parce
que je pense que le boxeur belge est
loin d'être fou aussi comme je pense que
lui lui accorder sa revanche sur un
petit peu se mettre en danger parce que
lui il est cuit n'est pas courant c'est
étonnant voyez pour moi lui va pas
accepter
là où je suis assez d'accord avec le
principe de marvin de dire on se revoit
dans deux mois c'est que si marvin a
l'impression de ne pas être de ne pas
avoir été attaqué par rapport à sa
préparation ça veut dire qu'il est
encore une marge et qui peut aller la
chercher sur les deux mois alors que
s'il belge lui il était à 100% de ses
moyens il a besoin de lui il a besoin
d'un sas de décompression pour pouvoir
repartir sur une préparation autres et
donc donc je comprends pourquoi mervyn
veut le veulent ils cherché très
rapidement et puis après parce que il
faut aussi nous il faut aussi se nourrir
de cette déception et c'est elle qui va
le pousser à retourner sur les
ça compense fronde de ses moyens qu'est
ce qui est familier aux problèmes
familiaux il a eu beau coup d'arrêt dans
sa préparation sur les deux derniers
mois il a dû perdre également beaucoup
de poids ce qui la fatigue est forcément
pour ce combat
hélène il a 27 ans qu'il aura d'autres
occasions questions sur ce je pense
qu'il a encore quelques années la boxer
est pas 27 en mai mais bon on va prendre
l'exemple de mahmoudi le prénom a dit la
maladie l'avs ou m midi qui combat
encore ça laisse le temps à marvin je
pense parler à football désolé désolé
laine vous avez vous la lisez là je
pense qu'entre ici quelques paris tire
aussi une leçon
voilà la configuration de ce qui s'est
passé donc on l'attend sur les prochains
on va voir la petite cloche pour passer
au thème suivant va maintenant parler un
football dans le championnat de première
division de district en match en retard
maurepas s'est imposé 3 0 face à
montesson ce dimanche 24 février avec
trois buts de leur attaquant vedette
yacoub belfodil on écoute le héros du
jour au micro de tv 78 votre but
on entend surtout pour la victoire aussi
apple ça fait du bien de renouer avec la
victoire à domicile devant nos
supporters m'ont qu' on est content on
est content l'attaquant est un habitué
des triplés il avait déjà marqué trois
buts en début de saison contre
sartrouville ce dimanche il a notamment
marqué un deuxième but plein de sang
froid il nous explique son but le
deuxième but c'est bah je pars au bon
moment et me de france parade versé
pensé que j'étais hors jeu alors que non
moi je vois bien que je pars je donc j'y
vais après le gardien après certes
chambrer un peu mais je l'a attendu pour
le remettre accroché mais je m'excuse
mais voilà ça fait partie du jeu c'est
le football
par là on fait un peu un peu de choses
sur le terrain voilà ep voilà on met le
deuxième but et on écoute et là ni vous
a plu ce but ça fait un peu d'une de
cour de récré en même temps il marque un
donc c'est très bien c'est comme au
rugby sur un trois contre un quand on va
quand on va passer la ville à l'aller
chambre et le gardien pour l'y mettre en
deuxième crochet et puis et puis marquer
sous son nez devant le passé deux fois
valait mieux qui le marque t elle
s'arrêter dommages à petit ça fait
partie du show ou pas il le dit dans son
interview ça fait partie du show du
synthé puis ça fait surtout partie de la
deûle à la prise de balle si chic ou
psychologique
il enfonce un peu en même temps employé
ou les images on voit qu'il a la régie
des déséquilibres au moment où il veut
frapper et je pense que c'est pour ça
qu'il va chercher le deuxième crochet
par ce que il se dit il
tout un gain de 1,18 doute oui et on
voit de long voile léger déséquilibre et
cette pensée qui se reprend mais en
effet on vient pas posé la question
devant lui posera si on repose sur notre
match
la question sur cette aile faut-il
retenir seulement la performance d'un
joueur sur ce type de match non non non
genre ça a été le premier à dégainer
non parce que les qualités individuelles
d'un joueur dans un sport collectif
ça ça mais ça apporte une pierre à
l'édifice
mais c'est quand même un sport collectif
donc c'est un collectif qui qui amène
les résultats après il ya les
individualités qui fait que alors on
peut quand on a des bons joueurs comme
lui qui a l'air un petit peu je ne sais
pas je ne connais pas et qu'elle a
peut-être un petit peu au moins sur ce
match au dessus du lot voilà c'était son
jour
mais c'est quand même l'équipe qui a
gagné c'est pas un joueur qui gagne les
une équipe dans une gazette pour
collectif états unis qui peuvent voir
pierre chevalier c'est l'équipe qui
détermine la victoire et c'est
l'attaquant là dans son bonjour qui
détermine le score on sait c'est grâce
grâce au travail collectif des onze ce
cet attaquant dont celle au job a pu a
pu briller et maître cera trek un
globule tiens donc joly il permet en
plus même de travail et un sur l'appui
psychologique autour du gardien et de le
chambrer en même temps donc il s'est vu
refusé un autre but également mais comme
dijon cc c'est d'abord l'équipe est là
il était dans son jour il met les 3 ml 3
buts je pense que c'est toute l'équipe
au diapason avec ceux avec cet attaquant
réussite on met souvent quand même en
avant les attaquants dans ce type de
match avec trois buts inscrits vous
comprenez ça y'a nigeria moi je vous dis
quand même répondre à la question de
base à celle là c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment un travail d'équipé parce que
vous l'attaquant fait son job et
marquent trois buts messi
si on en prend quatre derrière on perd
le match donc donc là voilà c'est le
sait l'équipe qui amène le résultat
maintenant pour répondre à la deuxième
question reformulée là s'il vous plaît
est ce qu'on met toujours un attaquant
les en valeur les attaquants plus que
les clés mais bien sûr mais bien sûr
puisque puisque c'est lui qui termine
ses soins l'attaquant qui détermine
l'action et on met toujours en avant le
buteur on met pas en avant de
l'attaquant va prendre l'exemple de
bagéens pavard qui qui marque le but en
coupe du monde est très beau mais ça
n'empêche que c'est le buteur qui est
mis en avant et ce n'est pas simplement
le ce n'est pas simplement le
l'attaquant c'est vrai que le fait de
mettre un but le fait de mettre un but
au foot s'est concrétisée l'action s'est
concrétisé le ccc marquer au score et
donc du coup en effet ces masses et le
c'est celui qui marque qui est qui le le
joueur du match
jean finalement en football on parle de
plus en plus de statistiques
il a dit par exemple dans son interview
qu'il avait réalisé un hat trick en
début de saison un trick là le week-end
dernier
finalement le foot ça devient des
statistiques si on regarde bien les
statistiques sur le nombre de buts oui
ça c'est mon et stand the rain on pourra
pas exister mais on est un attaquant
lancé c'est très tôt investi qui ça
c'est pour ceux pour flatter leur égo
mais sinon bon après après pour se bien
souvent dans les autres clubs
un attaquant par exemple souvent en
hiver fait quand on regarde quand on
prend les attaquants dans le football on
dit baisse ce jour là la saison dernière
il a marqué le marquer 25 buts ont
cueilli tourne et tourne avec 20 buts
par saison et autant dans la décisive
parce que là-bas d'accéder au site
apporte moi c'est surtout les bouquins
et donc c'est vrai que par rapport par
rapport à ceux à cette monnaie d'échangé
entre guillemets pour ce poste là c'est
tout mais après bon mise à part c'était
le flatter leur égo mais c'est juste
qu'on a des outils différents pour
poursuivre au moins ces statistiques là
et en premier de tous c'est la vidéo les
années vidéo
maintenant à tous les niveaux même au
niveau amateur quelles que soient les
sports d'ailleurs on regarde la vidéo on
fait pas des séances à chaque match et
des préparations vidéo notamment au
niveau amateur mais mais on a désormais
des de nombreux outils qui nous
permettent de gérer les stats de gérer
les adversaires de placer des stratégies
de les suivre et regarder un petit peu
ce que ça a donné en termes de résultats
je suis d'accord sur les statistiques
mais c'est vrai que un attaquant on va
râler synthétique qui vont de nombre de
buts marqués mais quand vous allez avoir
un milieu de terrain ça va être le
nombre de kilomètres qui va avoir
parcouru pendant 1 pendant le match
donc oui bien sûr que l'iliade et il ya
des statistiques et qu'elles sont
importantes pour pouvoir faire
progresser et faire avancer l'équipe
après ce niveau là peut-être que juste
l'attaquant est mis en avant
finalement au niveau du nombre de buts
plutôt qu'un milieu de terrain qui
courent 10 15 km dans le match un milieu
de terrain à ce niveau là c'est les
observateurs qui vont pouvoir le
détecter et voir que le gars a une vraie
influence sur sur le sur le jeu on n'est
pas c'est vrai que c'est un peu plus
difficile de sortir mais il ya des gens
qui ont l'oeil pour ça et c'est à eux de
sérieux travail est d'aller voir d'aller
dette de 2,2 pouvoir détecter ces
talents là qu'ils sont capables de
courir en était un de manière à définir
merci papa est en tout cas cinquième du
championnat après cette victoire 3-0
contre montesson on va maintenant passer
à notre page coup de projecteur
[Musique]
on prend maintenant la direction de
plaisir des entraîneurs en kilt c'était
l'image insolite de ce samedi 23 février
au stade robert barran le club écossais
de lyme lythgoe venu affronter sur le
terrain une équipe composée de joueurs
locaux de plaisir et de sportifs des
entreprises au bruit et mines orange
tout cela dans le cadre d'un partenariat
créé en parallèle du tournoi des six
nations sur le terrain les français
l'emportent 38 à 24
on écoute les réactions on a beau faire
la fête la veille sur le terrain il ya
pu y a plus d'amitié pendant deux fois
quarante minutes
donc bon match c'était un match très dur
aujourd'hui il beaucoup d'essais pour
les deux équipes très agréable très dur
beaucoup de joueurs ont été en
difficulté aujourd'hui mais nous allons
passer un bon moment après le match le
mans
hélène vous aviez une petite remarque je
suis déçu que les joueurs soient pas en
kilt parce qu'une explication messieurs
les rugbymans cette année voilà si vous
voulez du public si vous voulez être su
forcer tous avons après il ya tout ce
qu'il faut faire face il portera
questions sur ce thème
doit-on reproduire ce type d'initiative
vous allé tellement vite que vous faites
tomber la raquette
l'arrêté de 100 go oui bien sûr parce
que ça reste un match amical maintenant
maintenant il faut que ce soit des
équipes de valeur de valeurs proches
pour que pour que tous puissent y
prendre du plaisir parce que si si vous
rencontrez un adversaire qui vous qui
vous sur surclasse ben vous n'apprenez
rien et vous ne vous ne progressait pas
donc là maintenant la seule chose que je
trouve dommage c'est que la france n'ait
pas réussi fin que le territoire n'est
pas réussi à avoir juste une équipe qui
a l'habitude de jouer ensemble
alors au final ils gagnent quand même
mais on prend des joueurs d'une équipe
on prend des joueurs d'un entreprises
demandeuses de deux entreprises pour
pouvoir faire une équipe
je suis pas sûr qu'ils aient des
automatismes et voilà c'est un peu ça
leur sauce ils ont pu préparer le match
et qu'ils ont pu s'entraîner ensemble
mais c'est vrai que là ça fait un peu ça
fait un peu un matin je sais pas ce que
vous en pensez genre non mais là non
mais c'est non mais c'est très bien il
s'est très bien passé c'est du sport
celui rugby c'est parfait mais impose un
centre et la marche populaire à la ccj
lourd et coll
mais alors je m'entends tu peux jouer
d'emblée c'est non mais c'est sûr mais
seriez peut y jouer
c'est pas du tout péjoratif ce que je
dis ce que je dis là c'est que ces voilà
c'est ça se fait depuis très très
longtemps et ça a toujours existé lors
des rencontres du tournoi payer il ya
des équipes qui se déplacent qui
viennent qui profites pour aller voir le
match international
et voilà c'est l'esprit du tournoi et là
c'est pas le match nenê n'est que n'est
que le support fraîchement d'une à mon
avis une courte à bord d'un gros
week-end de fête
je vais vous raconter le programme du
week end
la veille ils ont manqué y manger
ensemble paella alors monde ne me
demandez pas pourquoi ils ont mangé le
bayer la c6 ensuite dormi chez les
joueurs français les écossais ont dormi
chez les français le samedi matin ils
ont joué ensemble
le match de rugby et le samedi après
midi ils sont allés au stade de vollard
là c'était un week end
voilà c'est le prétexte c'est voilà
l'esprit du tournoi comme dit pierre et
c'est le prétexte en or le match
opposait de s'entraîner c'est vraiment
pour dire on joue au rugby on fait une
rencontre internationale
c'est plus un prétexte pour voilà
c'était beau texte mais c'est si c'est
le cas c'est le ca
c'est le beach-volley l'été à la plage
alors voilà tout à fait c'est comme pour
après mais à créer créer l'année
prochaine je de l'impact quand même sera
de type de oui j'espère qu'à pas eu de
blessés message même pas vite je crois
tu penses que c'est les français qui
s'est fait ces faits danseuse dans cet
esprit de garder sa plaque non mais oui
/ non mais attendez c'est pas besoin
mais léger dire sinon péjoratif mais
disons que c'est pas vraiment quand on
vole une ouverture la bombe non mais
c'est bien et c'est bien c'est super
fier il y avait plusieurs
il y avait plusieurs signes qui est moi
qui m'ont fait plaisir sur le match
international france ecosse là c'est
justement le retour à l'essence même de
l'esprit du tournoi des cinq nations
puis des six nations derrière c'est que
chaque match international ce soit en
france en irlande en angleterre pays de
galles écosse et c'est même en italie
c'est que c'est propice
justement à ce type des changes
paneuropéen autour du rugby des valeurs
des fameuses valeurs dont on parle
régulièrement où justement des équipes
des équipes en profitent pour faire une
tournée faire une tournée que ce soit
des équipes de jeunes des équipes de
plus vieux des équipes de très violents
du cancer ne sont pas très très vieux
mais ça va super vite et c'est ça
l'esprit du tournoi on avait le retour
du match france ecosse à 15 heures 15
heures 15 un vrai horaires de tournoi il
y aller déjeuner avant il ya des petits
déjeuners avant est allé soirée d'avant
hier lé dinh aidé avant les matches et
tout ça dans le dans le plus pur esprit
rugby tout le monde se retrouve au stade
le stade était plein pas craquer mais
presque plein à 77 mille personnes il y
avait une ambiance de feu et je pense
que justement l'horaire et l'ambiance
évidemment la météo ne sont pas
étrangers à ce succès là l'année
prochaine en tout cas ce sont les
français qui iront en écosse
maintenant à notre rubrique focus du
cyclisme sur piste dans ce focus une
très mauvaise nouvelle pour ryan et la
halle il ne participera pas aux
championnats du monde en pologne
compétition organisée de ce mercredi 27
février au dimanche 3 mars
annoncé comme la future pépite du
cyclisme français le pistard de 20 ans
s'est blessé lors d'un entraînement
juste avant le départ l'isérois qui
s'entraîne avec le pôle olympique de
saint quentin en yvelines ne participera
donc pas à ses deuxièmes championnats du
monde
il est remplacé par quentin caleyron du
vélo-club elancourt saint quentin en
yvelines pour la compétition la question
sur ce thème
est ce que cette blessure est un frein
pour sa carrière
oui ou non on fait un petit duel entre
hélène et yann dujarrier élèves n'ont de
toute façon c'est pas assez c'est pas un
avantage c'est toujours un france etc
des expériences en moins c'est de la
préparation au moins c'est de la
récupération voilà à travailler on peut
pas dire qu'ils gagnent ou pour moi il
perd quelque chose après qu'est-ce qui
peut y faire de plus rien je suis
d'accord avec hélène jeu même si pour
moi je pense que ce n'est pas un frein
puisqu'il n'a que 20 ans mais en effet
tout ce que elle est bien de mettre en
avant c'est la vérité c'est vrai qu'ils
perdent des occasions il va manquer de
il va manquer cet événement est donc il
ne prendra pas en expérience maintenant
l'expérience à chaque à chaque match à
chaque match que vous pouvez vous pouvez
vous confronter aux meilleurs vous
gagner en expérience
vous pourrez vous avez fait une erreur à
tel moment et bien vous de l'art c'est
quand vous êtes un minimum intelligent
on va dire vous de l'art produirait pas
après et donc est donc à chaque fois il
faut tout ce que vous avez fait une
première fois à la tête vous allez
trouver un autre une autre technique
pour pouvoir le pour pouvoir le battre
vous pouvez pas si vous faites deux fois
la même chose vous ne gagnerez une fois
mais vous donnerez pas d'eux parce que
l'autre aura qu essayer de trouver une
parade à la face sauf si vous êtes
chronométriquement beaucoup plus fort à
la grosse différence du du du 100 m sur
/ en athlétisme ou c'est une course en
ligne droite et en effet vous avez des
adversaires mais tout le monde est sur
la même mais me veil un vrai aspect
tactique et technique sur le dans dans
un match de vitesse donc en dehors du
manque d'expérience pour moi c'est pas
c'est pas un frein on revient toujours
plus forts d'une blessure je vais
prendre des exemples comme laurent
jalabert il ya beaucoup de grands
athlètes qui sont blessés et qui sont
revenus plus forts plus fort après une
blessure donc ryan voilà il va il va
voir un coup au moral
c'est sûr maintenant il y aura les
championnats de france au mois de mai au
mois d'août au mois d'août et au mois de
mai on rencontre déjà des athlètes qui
sont de niveau international l'aller les
coupes du monde vont revenir à partir du
mois d'octobre à novembre l'année
prochaine donc voilà c'est six mois
ces six mois vont passer très très vite
et ce ne sera qu'un une quinqua mauvais
souvenirs l'année prochaine quand il ira
participer aux jeux olympiques avec
l'équipe de france pierre chevalier il
ya quinze nous a convaincu jeudi je
dirais lier le diane était d'accord avec
les avec l aide dont il n'avait pas
forcément à trancher tombés d'accord
mais c'est juste revenir il ya quinze
jours quand on évoquait justement la
qualité de l'équipe qui avait été
sélectionnée est ce qu'elle est vraiment
jusqu'au bout avec avec la possibilité
d'intégrer un coup dur est de pouvoir
remplacer au pied levé
a priori une des bonnes chances de
médaille
pour blessure donc là c est ce que la
sélection était vraiment été vraiment
aussi bonne qu'on l'avait trouvé il ya
quinze jours à yann n'intervenez pas sur
les courses la course par équipes du
sprint il intervenait que à titre
individuel sur la vitesse individuelle
et peut être guéri les chances de
médailles
donc voilà c'est peut-être une chance de
médaille en moins quentin quentin
caldéron est un est un est un cas les
rangs et et qui va lui qui va le
remplacer est un est un athlète qui n'a
pas autant d'expérience que karajan sauf
qu'il n'a pas le même âge mais il a 31
ans et c'est par contre il a autant
différence puisque c'est son premier
championnat du monde
il a participé à quelques coupe du monde
cet hiver voilà c'est un c'est un ancien
du bmx qui s'est mis à la piste ya il ya
très peu de temps et qui performent au
niveau mondial donc pour moi pour moi il
a largement le il a largement la place
pour pour pour le remplacer et voilà
surtout ça n'influe pas sur la
discipline la vitesse par équipes où les
lélés comment s'appellent les garçons
sont là et eux ne sont pas blessé il n'a
pas donné pas de problème donc sac pour
ryan c'est dommage de ne pas pouvoir
acquérir plus d'expérience on vient
d'avoir en direct la nature de la
blessure de rien et la halle par la
fédération française de cyclisme une
fracture d'un pied sur accident
domestique banal donc quand on l'entend
pas l'entraînement pas en compétition
partie genre une réaction j'avais des
informations qui vient la blessure la
blessure malheureusement fait partie du
quotidien du sportif
et là on peut dire que il se blesse au
mauvais moment parce qu'il se blesse
juste avant une compétition c'est même
pas rentrer internationale
coupe du monde ne s'est pas échappée la
demande pardon c'est pas c'est pas
anodin
ces mauvais moments mais malheureusement
ce sera plus au top mais ce sera pas
soutien provient il sa dernière blessure
cette manne salut retarde un petit peu
tout ce qui a été dit autour on va
maintenant passer notre page débats on
ouvre une page jeux olympiques de 2024
s'était fortement pressenti c'est
désormais officiel le comité
d'organisation de paris a proposé
d'intégrer le break dance au programme
des jo au parisien ce serait une
première pour ce sport qui est déjà
apparu ou jeux olympiques de la jeunesse
l'année dernière on écoute la réaction
de jean jé mad cofondateur de la
compagnie black blanc beur
ça me suggère un sentiment paradoxal
c'est que d'un côté
voilà une ultime reconnaissance d'un
savoir faire deux choses extrêmement et
du corps et que complexe le beau à voir
et qui devient un sport de compétition
c'est à dire qui affirme nettement
linverse finalement de ce qui l'a amené
à se développer comme un genre
stylistique de la danse hip hop à savoir
une danse qui porte un récit qui porte
un questionnement politique
un questionnement que culturelles et qui
a abandonné ce coup-ci inde justement
non pas contre la compétition mais pose
d'abord la compétition qu'on a à voir en
nous mêmes et non le principe d'être au
dessus des autres
la question sur ce thème pour ou contre
le break dance aux jo
vous êtes tous contre personne et pour
c'est comme si on remettait le pole
dance quoi c'est pareil c'est c'est en
c'est un sujet d'ailleurs mais je suis
assez mitigé parce qu'il ya une dizaine
de jours c'est possible
c'est déjà bien pour 2024 non mais c'est
dans les tuyaux déjà tout ça mais je
suis un peu mitigé parce que c'est de la
danse et des acrobaties mais j'ai
l'impression que ça c'est pas pour moi
c'est un sport assez exigeant
physiquement pour ça fasse partie des
géo j'aurais pas comment le traduire
mais simplement de la danse je trouve
que c'est trop c'est trop juste
finalement pour comparer il y a le
patinage artistique pour les jo c'est
s'est quand même dit j'avais juge
également et c'est que c'est plus cadré
ses plus fins et différence et je trouve
que ne vous a pas contre linge allait en
parler justement dire en cordura
discipline qui va être ou les où le
champion sera sera désigné par parent
par un panel de juges et donc du coût
des disques d'aidé contestation possible
et puis et puis sincèrement oued en
termes de d'efforts physiques
je sais qu'il a été demandé à la halle à
oui oui c'est bien sûr que c'est
physique mais c'est pas ce qu'on entend
par sport quand même et je sais qu'il a
été demandé à la pétanque
on en parle dans l'élite après de la
barrique et de porter des blue-jeans
pour que pour pouvoir montrer alice
aller au haut comité olympique qu'ils
avaient un esprit de sport et donc du
coup depuis une tenue sportive donc
depuis quelques depuis une année
les mecs sont tout le temps en suivant
vêtements ou alors en pantalon en toile
et c'est vraiment une tenue propre
propre et là un ciel et une tenue
officielle voilà propre maintenue
officiel là je suis désolé mais c'est un
sport que l'on peut pratiquer en jean et
gj du mal à j'ai du mal avec ça ça colle
pas avec avec la raison pour laquelle on
on a en tout cas les organisations
justifier ce choix
ils ont affirmé vouloir se connecter aux
sports qui cartonne partout dans le
monde afin d'apporter une dimension
urbaine au jeu voilà la raison c'est pas
sur cette arme est un constat la
question c'est justement qu'est-ce qui
procède pour pour le comité olympique
international de la sélection d'un sport
et de l'arrivée justement de d'un sport
que ya un cahier des charges en activité
comme comme le breakdance et cela sans
toucher la jeunesse
oui s est ce que c'est justement par on
va dire par prosélytisme et par
universalité pour pouvoir toucher le
plus de monde dans le monde et dans et
dans la rue notamment après les jo
et après cette exposition est le constat
je le fais par rapport à la par rapport
au gulf que je connais un peu mieux le
débat et le même s'il reste que le golf
est un sport était ce qui est un loisir
pour beaucoup la question se posait à
l'époque et en revanche la
reconnaissance du sport comme sport
olympique
c'est phénoménal pour pour une
discipline sportive cers à rentrer dans
le côté universel sportif mondial
tous les quatre ans est une exposition
absolument unique
je ne sais pas si aussi par m le
breakdance a besoin de ce coup de
projecteur là et si on répond aux
critères de coubertin en sélectionnant
une activité physique plus qu'un sport
avec avec le break dance
en tout cas pour le golf ça a permis de
passer un cap d'exposition et de
reconnaissance ya quand même un gros
côté artistique dans le royaume et ça
sera jugé et ça sera jugée comme comme
le patinage artistique homme et ça
marche comme les champs dévastés
qu'est-ce qu'elle n'a finalement ça
marche bien là dans ces cas là c'est
plus le constate il y as qu est ce que c
est ce que c'est vraiment un sport au
sens au sens physique et mentale du et
mentale du terrain ces disciplines
invités ou c'est une discipline qui va
rester habiter dans un premier temps
d'accord invités proposé comme sport
invités donc ce n'est pas encore
officiel en jeu leur appel et ça devrait
normalement rester une année au minimum
mais si les tests sont concluants ça
pour rester un petit peu plus
jean elles sont sceptiques sceptique je
suis pas sceptique
vous qui en avez moi je faisais dans ma
main je me faisais sur la tête
d'ailleurs j'ai les cheveux
non mais on est où et quand même d'aider
des jeux d'athènes et l'idée qu'on peut
se faire des jeux olympiques
est-ce qu'il faut pas les malins mais
évolue et je veux bien évolué malheureux
mais c'est qui alors certes qu'il est
les juges là c'est kamel ouali
jean paul gaultier non mais là on est
plus dans le on n'est plus dans
l'ambiance boîte de nuit
spectacle danse et non moi moi je fais
c'est quand même eux aussi on sait pour
moi on s'écarte quand même de l'image
l'image l'image athlétique sportive que
représentent les jeux olympiques tout
simplement là on est plus qu'un dans le
jeu théâtral dans le le côté le côté
spectacle et non pas le côté sportif
perturbé puisque je veux dire je pense
que oui je suis non je pense qu'en fait
si on considère que les les sportifs qui
intègre les géo et les disciplines qui
intègre les géo regroupe des athlètes
je veux bien qu'on ait de très bon break
dancer dans la discipline maintenant de
là à voir beaucoup de participants break
dancer français également mais est-ce
que ce soit vraiment oran d'athlètes
comme je peux voir ma joie je parle de
ma discipline mais en pole on a des
athlètes des athlètes de folie et c'est
tellement exigeant physiquement que je
peux comprendre que ce soit qu'on puisse
le proposer là ça me fait plus penser à
un loisir a peut-être un côté un peu
collectif ramener un petit peu du monde
et sert à mettre le projecteur dessus
mais de là à considérer que tous les
participants ou de ceux qui vont
s'intéresser sont des athlètes je pense
que on a pas on n'est pas mais le
nouveau là que la discipline qu'ils
s'infligent soit la même que beaucoup
d'athlètes de très haut niveau c'est
parce que sa demande au club je parle
même pas que de la préparation mais il
doit y avoir une grosse réparation pour
mille
la statue dans la variété de ce que tu
peux proposer dans sa jupe à la
créativité également d'avoir des juges
[Musique]
non non je compte faire face à la juge
hallée soit des initiants qui parce
qu'ils savent jugé justement la forme ça
va être si les fils il ya des figures
imposées oui ça va limiter la créativité
en fait c'est plutôt donc je viens de
soirée à bonaly qui était la seule fille
à pouvoir faire le salto arrière dès
qu'elle repart de le faire est la parade
de faire en compétition parce que
c'était pas une figure qui était qu'elle
est autorisée et qui était pas reconnue
et en effet ça peut le fait qu'ils les
jugent peu limité la créativité danseuse
dans ce cas là puisque pour la sécurité
de la tête on interdit alors que alors
que c'est quelque chose qu'elle faisait
en représentation très régulièrement en
tout cas le breakdance est apparu aux
jeux olympiques de la jeunesse en 2018
en argentine sous forme de battle
c'est-à-dire deux équipes qui
s'affrontent qui ont été départagés par
des juges et ça s'est très bien passé
les jets de pierres dans l'est dans
l'équipe de dans l'équipe de tony
estanguet détiennent togo qui sont aux
manettes de l'organisation des jo 2000
24 je trouve qu'il ya beaucoup de
meilleures idées en termes universités
l'universalité commencer votre scène par
exemple d'ouvrir le marathon au public
c'est à dire qu'ils vont là c'est sorti
cette semaine
proposé à proposer je sais pas combien
de personnes sont concernées mais en
tout cas de proposer à des runner de
pouvoir courir le marathon dans les
conditions olympiques ça c'est une idée
c'est génial une idée d'ouverture une
idée universelle qui va justement
permettre de faire passer les frontières
du sport est on est on est dans l'est
dans les valeurs de l'olympisme en plus
ça c'est une ça c'est une excellente
idée je suis pas sûr que le breakdance
au com sports invitée comme sport
olympique puisse avoir les meilleurs
jeunesse mais ça va toucher un cahier
des charges de ces faux militaires ça
devrait être ça qui les mène cette idée
mais vous avez dit oui à vienne sur la
partie sportive
on a des bons breakdancer parmi les
français je suis désolé mais pour moi la
pétanque est un sport qui est à la
pétanque avec le breakdance l'escaladent
pourrait faire son entrée aux jeux
olympiques de 2024 à paris ces
disciplines pratiquées par plus d'un
million de personnes chaque année en
france et 4e sport le plus testé dans
les lycées et collèges a été retenu par
le comité d'organisation
nous sommes allés du côté de l'une des
plus grandes salles de bloc verticale
art situé à montigny le bretonneux pour
recueillir les réactions
personnellement je trouve que c'est une
avancée quand même conséquente pour le
sport dans sa globalité mais c'est aussi
quelque chose qui qui était assez
attendue au vu de l'évolution du sport
depuis ces cinq dernières années
moi je trouve ça très bien ça va
permettre de démocratiser un petit peu
ce sport qui est très peu connue qui
commence à être un petit peu plus connus
ici en france notamment grâce aux salles
de bloc mais ça va permettre de faire
venir encore un petit peu plus de
demandes dans le sport c'est une
reconnaissance
oui tout à fait enfin l'escaladent on
sait que c'est un sport complet et on
comprenait pas trop pourquoi justement
c'était pas reconnue au niveau des jeux
olympiques et ça va donner une autre
dimension à souffrent la question sur ce
thème pour ou contre l' escalade au jo
alors là pareil pas de débat vous êtes
tous d'accord cette fois-ci genre de
mort vous qui avez testé l'escaladé
également j'ai fait beaucoup de choses
si j'écoute mais parce que metz a
rejoint l'exode ce que j'ai dit vous
allez donc des caméras mobiles et voilà
ça c'est du sport
ça c'est dit en gros c'est du sport
voilà c'est du sport à l'état pur moi
j'ai protégé pratiquer l'escaladé un peu
d'un point de vue technique d'un point
de vue analyse les voit les difficultés
en fins et les capacités qui fait
physique qu'il faut les préparatifs
voilà du du matériel du corps etc
on est vraiment dans des performances
physiques qui sont vraiment différentes
et pour moi au delà est beaucoup plus
identifiable et reconnaissable par
quelqu'un qui va regarder en break dance
on va
alors je vulgarise un peu nous on va
voir quelqu'un qui gesticulent un peu
qui va faire quelques figures mais on
peut pas savoir ce qui est fait alors
qu'en escalade c'est pas un novice
pourrait se dire ok la personne arrivant
où elle a terminé non on voit les
éléments techniques on voit la
difficulté on voit l'écart et exxon de
bloc maintenant tout le monde en a
approche de son proche de chez soi et
donc du coup on peut essayer et en se
recueillant ce qui serait rapidement
compte
et puis c'est beau à regarder au niveau
que ça que des hommes non non mais même
techniquement c'est c'est incroyable il
fait de telles connaissances et intel
une telle résistance
on prend je prends un exemple tout
simple d'une émission qui passent sur
sur sur la première chaîne de france et
qui s'appelle dj warriors et ce sont des
athlètes et ce sont souvent des des
jeunes becker fin des hommes qui font d
escalade qui font partie des meilleurs
donc ça montre bien la la
je précise pour les noms mais bien sûr
ce sera pas nous voir ailleurs ce sera
leur discipline ce sera une escalade
mais ce que je veux dire c'est que dans
le côté sportif
vous pouvez avoir des très très bon
athlète
si vous les mettez sur ce même parcours
et bien un gars qui finissent caladons
c'est pas d'une jaguar york sur un sur
ce type de parcours il va voir d'aisance
plus aura deux épreuves un
vraisemblablement pour l'instant deux
épreuves pour l'instant 3 pour moi ray
parce qu'il ya la peau pour moi enfin
les rumeurs il y aurait une épreuve de
bloc est une épreuve de vitesse deux
épreuves
et là il 25 mètres aussi ça s'appelle la
daube rôle et non le sénat a jugé plus
non mais non il y aura trois épreuves de
sur la nation escalade je suis retourné
on verra ça c'est une belle idée qui est
deux ou trois épreuves aussi la
troisième fois qu'ils appellent la voile
à poil plus de prendre sa vérité de
l'escaladé en plein air pourquoi qu'on a
quand même pas mal d'arguments en france
mais là c'est là on s'adresse à une
discipline sportive qui est de plus en
plus pratiquée dans des dans des
endroits qui sont là aussi il ya de la
rappeler de plus en plus nombreux et de
plus en plus accessibles partout c'est
on peut dire que c'est une activité à la
mode
elle rassemble du physique du mental et
de la technique
donc c'est là c'est là où on a on a
vraiment quelques quelques points forts
dans les disciplines sportives
bonne idée oui parce que là là on alors
c'est paradoxal par rapport à ce qu'on
disait au niveau du breakdance et qu'on
sait qu'on s'adresse à un public
nombreux et qui sera après le après les
épreuves olympiques encore plus nombreux
et je rappelle également que l' escalade
sera au programme des jeux olympiques de
2020 à tokyo c'est à dire qu'il y aura
déjà eu un précédent en 2034 c'est
encore mieux ça veut dire qu'en gros on
pourra se roder et les différents les
deux comités d'organisation pour on se
parlait justement pour réussir
l'organisation de cette partie cette
partie là qui se fera qui sera
vraisemblablement en indoor donc avec
avec la possibilité d'accueillir du
public et voire de faire monter une
certaine ambiance
il devrait y avoir c'est 72 athlètes au
total
normalement contre 40 parce que pour
l'instant aux jo de tokyo il n'y aurait
qu'une seule épreuve
20 20 contre 20 10 contre 10 et je pense
qu'on aurait besoin de l'autre côté
d'ici 2024 on n'aura pas de mal à
trouver notamment pour les équipes de
france des athlètes des athlètes
performants sur cette discipline a déjà
au niveau mondial qui sont qui sont qui
font partie des meilleurs mondiaux il
s'entraîne d'ailleurs averti callaert à
mon team l'honneur ou demande de
l'équipe de france
alors si les quatre disciplines invités
ont le sourire le coup a été rude pour
certains sports et notamment la pétanque
l'un des favoris pour intégrer les jo de
2024 n'a finalement pas été retenu par
les organisateurs nous sommes allés du
côté de guyancourt lors d'un tournoi ce
dimanche 24 février pour recueillir des
réactions moi je suis déçu mais on a mon
sens sur le sport que j'ai eus qu'ils
étaient
inscrits et très médiatisée chez les
jeunes je sais qu'il ya beaucoup qui
sont remontés après je pense que c'est
médiatique au niveau des redevances télé
petit doit avoir des malheureusement on
n en parle et qui 21 qui met en vous
même axe telus tv fil 78 n'a pas
beaucoup tiennent on va dire qu'ils
mettent en valeur la pétanque
donc du coup je pense que c'est dû à ça
c'est plus médiatiques qu'autre chose tv
78 non plus tv fil 78 la chaîne l'équipe
la question sur ce thème fallait-il
intégrer la pétanque aux jo pour wii ou
du français
pour hélène vous vous êtes partagés gens
vous êtes partagés pierre ont fait un
petit duel de retour entre hélène et
yann dujarrier hélène ouais alors la
pétanque c'est très bien mais pour moi
ça rejoint un petit peu le débat qu'on
avait eue sur sur le bridge les échecs
et ses fins pour moi c'est pas assez
physique s'est passé non c'est pas assez
physique
voilà pour ce soit au fond des jo yann
guerrier c'est vrai regard étoiles à
raison on avait placé la ccl plus c'est
ainsi que cela petit coeur qui parle
bien sûr c'est ça c'est le plus gros
match mais le plus grand événement
mondial en sport enfin en pétanque
c'est le tournant de la marseillaise et
pour moi voilà la france la france fait
partie des plus grosses nations
des plus grandes nations mondiales sur
sur cet avis et madagascar et la glace
car tout à fait et c'est pareil ça
aurait été très bien que madagascar
puisse avoir aussi sa médaille sa
médaille olympique
j'ai cherché alors c'était l'un d'eux
j'ai regardé combien médaille de l'inde
avait remportée aux jeux olympiques j'ai
par aider madagascar combien du coup
l'un de ses 12 n 12 est une douzaine de
médailles olympiques et alors
principalement sur le
cliquez ouais c'est ça c'est mignon ça
donc j'ai cherché un petit peu d'infos
mais c'est vrai que j'oublie de regarder
pour madagascar et ça aurait été énorme
de voir madagascar avec une année
olympique j'ai pas le souvenir qui est
beaucoup de médailles au nac d'ailleurs
celle de l'inde en route des
championnats du monde je crois il ya
trois ans de pétanque de piétons et bien
je sers bien sûr mais justement ils ont
la capacité d'avoir une médaille
olympique et je suis pas sûr que dans
toutes les disciplines autres et
madagascar et déjà remporté des
médailles olympiques
donc voilà je trouve que je trouve que
c'est un petit peu un petit peu de
matches pour ça pour ce côté pour ce
côté un petit peu exotique mais alors
pour la france voilà moi je enfin c'est
quand même le la discipline que je veux
parler de sport mais la discipline qu'on
pratique tous les thés aux bordeaux bord
de l'apéro au bord de la piscine ou du
lot mouloud n'est pas ça le problème il
ya de l'appétence finalement pour
intégrer les jeux olympiques
ouais mais bien sûr que bien sûr que
c'est ça le problème mais quand on
regarde la chaîne l'équipe et est une
retransmet tous les jours de 11h à 14h
des nains des notes des épreuves de
pétanque en ce moment c'est vrai que
quand on voit là
1 l'éléphant la beauté du geste et puis
enfin des supercars au québec arrive à
faire quand il pointe d'arriver à mettre
la balle la falsab la boule où ils
veulent
c'est c'est juste impressionnant et donc
il ya vraiment un vrai travail illégal
et les terrains sont parfois
catastrophiques d'un seul coup il va
voir un holà sur un autre tournoi ils
vont avoir un billard et donc on voit la
différence de jeu d'un terrain à l'autre
moi c'est vraiment quelque chose que que
j'aime et j'adore regarder la pétanque à
la télé mais j'aime aussi regarder le
curling donc je suis pas tranquille mais
non j'aime j'aime aussi j'aime aussi la
formule 1 j'aime j'aime le vélo je vais
tout vous êtes comme moi vous avez
regardé car des matchs de foot gkd p2i
hier soir à la télé voilà bien sûr
j'aime le sport à la télé et pour moi
les ligier hausse et ces quinze jours de
ces quinze jours d'hibernation donc
c'est un réel plaisir
mais voilà il ya pour moi la pétanque je
trouve ça dommage de pas l'avoir ne pas
l'avoir intégré sur sur cette olympiade
pierre chevallier vous était mitigé
parce que dans la discussion sport ou
passeport il manque quelques critères il
ya du ya des techniques il ya un peu de
mental pas forcément beaucoup de
physique
en revanche ce qui me faisait hésiter
c'est que ça il ya un côté vraiment
universelle en france
évidemment c'est culturel c'est même
même mons et régionales sur sur les
origines mais maman s'est pratiqué un
peu partout c'est pratiqué au niveau
amateur et même plus qu amateur puisque
comme tu le disais c'est pratiqué dans
les chaumières et dans les toutes les
maisons notamment de vacances ou de
campagne dès qu'on a une occasion voilà
c'est ce qui me fait hésiter sur le fait
de dire est ce que oui c'est dieu oui
c'est un regret de ne pas la voir ou non
c'est normal parce qu'il manque certains
critères sportifs pour la sélection
finale
mais c'est une question se pose si on
met la pétanque pourquoi pas le bol qui
genre vous avez entendus sur la question
pourtant vous êtes un amateur également
de fétan de chiens mais c'étaient les
boules c'est france est un des clubs
peut jouer avec les boules
donc ça tout le monde le sait bien que
ça s'appelait mai
voilà c'était moi je me suis-je étaient
mitigées comme bien pour les mêmes
raisons d'ailleurs parce qu' il manque
quand même le petit côté effort physique
est quand même plus facile à enlever le
coup de queue d'affaires calvet des
haltères mais bon donc c'était le même
le même des mots qu'on a eues ici et les
maladies avec le bridge avec toutes ces
disciplines
les échecs et les échecs sont là toutes
ces disciplines qui où l'immense imago
même qu'elle était un peu plus
travail physique quand même dans la paix
tant que dans les échecs ou le bridge
wiland oui oui bien sûr bien sûr du tout
parce qu'il faut quand même bon la
stratégie et la stratégie mission c'est
compliqué chacun un petit peu des
avantages mais si on refuse le fin si on
est un peu cohérent si on dit non
breakdance qui officie mais voilà il
faut être cohérent et en effet la bourse
alors la pétanque quand même fait partie
du top 10 des sports en france avec le
plus de licenciés un peu plus de trois
cent mille licenciés dans l'hexagone
gabriel mardi 10 mai pour ça que je dis
que c'est l'olympiade c'est vraiment
l'olympiade où il fallait intégrer la
pétanque mais oui avait son milieu à
paris je veux dire si on met la pétanque
à los angeles ça n'a pas lieu d'être
et là je pense que c'était vraiment le
sport local qui pouvaient être présentés
maintenant ou jamais c'est bien tu
arrives à la shoah venegas car ça fait
rouler je suis mais la pétanque en
france c'est comme le match de rugby des
écossais en france il soit venu c'est
pour faire une java pendant le week-end
et c'est ça sert de d'excusés la peta et
c'est pareil il ya beaucoup de
pratiquants pourquoi parce que mon côté
que l'on connaît le côté festif qui va
autour de cette discipline a réalisé
je n'ai pas cité avec mon ipod et partir
jouer avec moi avec modération c'est
quand même un sport qui n'est pas
forcément réputé pour être jeune et
pourtant à guyancourt il y avait quand
même énormément de jeunes sous l'ére
argent tu fais ça avec d'autres sports
d'autres activités d'autres activités en
loisir pur ou
c'est un complice jean du monde le
champion du monde de tir de tir il a
moins de 25 ans à deux pas de mémoire
parce que ça vient tout juste de la
série glee la fina sur l'équipe on avait
reçu une élite de jeu les 2 les deux
finalistes s'étaient déjà d'un design
moins de 30 ans on va terminer par une
citation à la fin de cette émission a
terminé par une citation de william ben
hogan l'un des plus grands joueurs de
l'histoire du golf qui a été en activité
dans les années 30 et 50 jusqu'aux
années 50 sa citation
si nous vous n'arrivez pas à surpasser
les autres travailler plus fort que je
vous laisse méditer sur cette phrase à
bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]